D
TRUMP AS PRESIDENT, HE WOULD
NOTE THE MEDIA MOB AND OTHERS
WOULD BE SAYING IT.
IT WAS -- HERE IS SOUTH FLORIDA
-- SOUTH CAROLINA SENATOR
LINDSEY GRAHAM.
YOU HAVE BEEN SAYING IT.
SENATOR KENNEDY HAS BEEN SAYING
IT AND SENATOR RAND PAUL HAS
BEEN SAYING IT AND I CREDIT ALL
OF YOU.
LET'S START WITH THE BASICS.
WHY -- PLEASE TELL ME.
IN THE NAME OF JESUS IN HEAVEN.
WHY WOULD WE GIVE CHINA AND
THEIR WUHAN LAB OF VIROLOGY ONE
SINGLE SOLITARY PENNY?
LET'S START THERE.
>> NUMBER ONE, IT SEEMS TO ME
CHINA HAS A LOT OF MONEY.
THEY CAN PAY FOR THEIR OWN
RESEARCH.
THE MOST STUNNING THING OUT OF
YOUR MONOLOGUE TO ME WAS THE
IDEA THAT DR. FAUCI DOES NOT
BELIEVE THAT IT IS IN CHINA'S
INTEREST TO LIE ABOUT THE LEAK
IN THEIR LAB.
THE PERSON FROM NBC ASKING,
ISN'T IT IN THEIR INTEREST TO
LOGIC OF THE WORLD AND NOT ADMIT
IT CAME FROM THE POINT LEAD
BECAUSE IT WOULD MAKE THEM LOOK
TERRIBLE?
IF YOU CAN'T FIGURE THAT OUT,
YOU GOT A REAL PROBLEM ON YOUR
HANDS.
CANDOR AND OPENNESS AND PRINTED
DO NOT GO IN THE SAME SENTENCE
WHEN IT COMES TO CHINA.
CALL DR. FAUCI BEFORE THE SENATE
AND THE HOUSE?
ALLOWED THE PEOPLE IN THE STATE
THE DEPARTMENT WHO ARE SILENCED
ABOUT PUSHING THE LAB LEAK THEOY
TO HAVE THEIR SAY.
HOLD THOSE RESPONSIBLE WHO
SHUTDOWN THIS CONVERSATION, MAKE
SURE THEY ARE FIRED.
AND GET TO THE BOTTOM OF WHAT
HAPPENED AND FINALLY, INTRODUCE
SANCTIONS BIPARTISAN AGAINST
CHINA IF THEY DON'T COOPERATE
WITH INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY.
THEY WILL NEVER TELL YOU THE
TRUTH UNTIL THEY ARE MADE TO DO
SO.
>> Sean: HE WAS TOLD
JANUARY 31st, 10 DAYS AFTER
THE FIRST IDENTIFIED CASE OF
CORONA IN THE WEST PAPER.
HE WAS TOLD TO.
DONALD TRUMP PUT IN PLACE THAT
XENOPHOBIC, HISTORICAL --
HYSTERICAL TRAVEL BAN.
COUNTLESS HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF LIVES THAT THE ONE THAT JOE
CALLED XENOPHOBIC, HISTORICAL,
AND THOSE HYSTERICAL AND ALL THE
ATTENDEES INTO HE WAS TOLD IT
LOOKS ENGINEERED.
THAT THE SEQUENCE OF THE VIRUS
SHOW EVERY INDICATION THAT IN
FACT THIS GAIN OF FUNCTION HAD
HAPPENED.
TEN DAYS IN.
NOW, THE QUESTION IS, -- BUT
THIS IS THE PROBLEM.
THIS IS WHY WE NEED TO CALL
DR. FAUCI.
DOESN'T THIS REMIND YOU ABOUT
THE --
>> Sean: YEAH, A LOT.
>> WE KNEW IT WAS BAD.
I?
OKAY BECAUSE THEY KNEW IT WAS
BAD.
BUT THEY HAD AN OUTCOME THEY
WANTED WHICH WAS TO BLAME TRUMP.
THEY SHUT DOWN THE IDEA THAT IT
IT CAME FROM THE LAB BECAUSE THE
CHINESE SCIENTISTS, THEY WILL
NEVER ADMIT TO THAT BECAUSE IT
MAKES THEM LOOK INCOMPETENT.
AND THE AMERICAN SCIENTISTS WHO
HAVE A WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE CHINESE SCIENTISTS, IT WOULD
MAKE THEM LOOK INCOMPETENT.
WE NEED SOMEBODY OUTSIDE OF THE
SCIENCE WORLD TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THIS AND I THINK THIS
IS A JOB FOR CONGRESS.
>> Sean: THE SENATOR, WE NOW
HAVE EVIDENCE THAT FIRST WE
PLAYED THE TAPE MANY TIMES.
JOE BIDEN, THREE SEPARATE
OCCASIONS.
I NEVER TALK TO MY SON HUNTER
ABOUT HIS BUSINESS DEALINGS.
NEVER.
NOW WE GOT PICTURES.
OF JOE AND RESTAURANTS WITH
OLIGARCHS FROM KAZAKHSTAN,
UKRAINE, RUSSIA, ET CETERA, ET
CETERA.
DOES AMERICA NOW HAVE TO WORRY
THAT THE CHINESE HAVE
COMPROMISING MATERIAL ON THE
BIDEN FAMILY BECAUSE IN MY VIEW,
THERE'S NO RATIONAL REASON THAT
THE PRESIDENT WOULD GIVE A
WAIVER FOR PUTIN TO BUILD HIS
PIPELINE WILL TAKING AWAY
AMERICAN JOBS AND AMERICAN
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE.
ON THE OTHER HAND, DOES NOT MAKE
ANY SENSE LIKE OPEN STACKS AND
DEUTSCHE BANK -- GOLDMAN SACHS
AND DEUTSCHE BANK AND DP MORGAN
AND SHE IS, IT DID NOT GET THE
1.5 BILLION-DOLLAR DEAL WITH THE
BANK OF CHINA.
AT HUNDRED GOT IT, THE CRACK
ADDICT LIKE YOU EXPLAIN TO ME.
WE HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THIS
RESTRICTION COME FROM MICE.
IF IT WAS DONALD TRUMP AS
PRESIDENT, THAT WILL BE THE
NARRATIVE EVERY SINGLE SECOND,
HOUR OF EVERY 24 HOUR DAY.
>> ABSOLUTELY CRUSH ON, BECAUSE
YOU HAVE A RATIONAL BUSINESS
RELATIONSHIPS.
WHY WOULD A BANK IN CHINA GIVE
HUNTER BIDEN MONEY EXCEPT FOR
THE FACT THAT HE HAS CONNECTIONS
TO VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN?
WHY IS HE ON -- BOARD IN THE
UKRAINE IF HE DOES NOT KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT THE OIL AND GAS
BUSINESS BECAUSE OF HIS LAST
NAME AND THE FACT THAT VICE
PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS IN CHARGE OF
ROOTING OUT CORRUPTION IN THE
UKRAINE.
IT DEFIES COMMON SENSE THAT
THESE ARE NORMAL BUSINESS DEALS.
IS IT LOGICAL TO THINK THAT
SOMEHOW DUE TO HIS ACTIVITY IN
THE UKRAINE AND CHINA HE MAY
HAVE BEEN COMPROMISED?
I CAN GUARANTEE YOU THE
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT'S SON HAD
DONE THIS, OR VICE PRESIDENT,
REPUBLICAN, VICE PRESIDENT'S SON
HAD DONE THESE THINGS, THE FRONT
PAGE NEWS ALL OVER THE WORLD.
YOU AT A GOOD QUESTION.
HAS BEEN COMPROMISED?
WHAT EXPLAINS -- TO BUILD A
PIPELINE AND YOU SHUT ONE DOWN
IN YOUR OWN COUNTRY.
HOW DOES THAT MAKE SENSE?
>> Sean: WELL, IT DOES NOT PUT
YOU JUST GOT BACK FROM ISRAEL.
REAL QUICK.
I SEE NOTHING BUT AN UNMITIGATED
DISASTER A WEEK.
>> WELL, BB, DON'T COUNT HIM
OUT.
THE RIGHT, THE MIDDLE, AND THE
LEFT IN ISRAEL THAT THEY ARE
VERY WORRIED ABOUT THE IRAN
NUCLEAR DEAL.
THEY HATE THE JCPOA.
HE IS GOING TO CREATE A NUCLEAR
ARMS RACE.
THE HERBS ARE GOING TO WANT
THEIR OWN ENRICHMENT CAPABILITY
AND WE WILL HAVE IN HIS ARMS
RACE.
ISRAEL WILL NOT TOLERATE A
PROGRAM IN IRAN.
IF WE GO BACK, WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE A NUCLEAR ARMS RACE AND
YOU'RE GOING TO PUT ISRAEL IN A
BAD SPOT WHERE YOU WILL HAVE A
WAR BETWEEN IRAN AND ISRAEL IF
WE GO BACK INTO THIS BAD DEAL.
AND I HEARD THAT FROM E